This video is about learning.
Styles. What kind of learner are.
You? Oh yeah, I'm a visual.
Person. So like.
See things. Yeah. I think visual learning visual. I mean,
like I remember formulas like auditory.
I need to be like interacting with the material.
I like to learn by doing myself very hands on, hands on learner, hands on.
So like, if I have a motto, I'd like to look at that and look it over.
Pardon of this.
Video is sponsored by Google search.
There is this idea in education that everyone has their own preferred way of
learning their so-called learning style.
If information is presented in accordance with the learning style, well,
then they'll learn better. Now,
there are dozens of different learning style theories,
but the most common one identifies for learning styles, visual auditory,
reading, writing,
and kinesthetic or VA for short visual learners learn best from images,
demonstrations, and pictures. People.
May say things, but I can't really like take it in.
I just gotta see 'em act it out or write it or.
Something. Auditory learners learn best from listening to an explanation.
I cool.
I was always engaged in the lecture and that was usually good enough to pass a
test.
Reading, writing learners learn best from reading and writing.
Like I can get pretty much anything out of reading a textbook or something.
And can aesthetic learners learn best by doing physically interacting with the
world.
Hands on you. You have to touch things. You have to play with things. Uh,
you know, you have it's, it's a contact sport. You have to do it yourself.
I wanna try something with you, a little experiment.
I wanna show you 10 pictures of things.
And I don't want you to say anything while you're looking at them.
And at the end of the 10, you tell me how many you can remember. Okay. Okay.
Okay. Okay.
Now learning styles make intuitive sense because we know everyone different.
Some people have better spatial reasoning,
others have better listening comprehension.
We know some people are better readers while others are good with their hands.
And it.
Sort of very much fits with, um,
a broad strain of thought and sort of the recent Western tradition is like,
we're all unique. We're all different.
And so you don't wanna say like everybody,
he learns the same way that sort of conflicts with our feelings about what it
means to be.
Human.
So doesn't it make sense that people should learn better in their own preferred
learning style? Well,
teachers certainly seem to think so a survey of nearly 400 teachers from the UK
and the Netherlands found that over 90% believed that individuals learn better
when they receive information in their preferred learning style. Just.
Like every professor has a different style of teaching.
You have a different style of.
Learning, but when his teacher starts using visuals,
Jonathan finds it easier to focus and understand the material.
So he might be a visual learner.
Can you tell me what that means to you?
Like what does it mean to be a visual learner? To me,
it means that for me to learn something,
sometimes I need to draw it or I need to write it down or I need to see a
picture or a movie.
For example, science classes, I get bored easily just listening.
And I think it it's more interesting for me to actually be able to do it.
How do you.
Know that you're a visual learner? I don't,
I just assume to take advantage of learning styles.
Then teachers need to do two things.
First identify the learning style of each of their students.
And second teach each student in accordance with their learning style on
the VA website. It says,
once you know about VA a it's power to explain things will be a revelation,
but before you take an online learning styles quiz, it's a good idea to ask.
Do learning styles even exist? I mean, do you have one?
And if you're taught in accordance with it, would you learn better?
Well, you could test this by running a randomized control trial,
where first you would identify learners with at least two different learning
styles, say visual and auditory,
and then randomly assign the learners to one of two educational presentations,
one visual, one auditory. So for half of the students,
the experience will match their learning style and for the other half it won't.
And then you give everyone the same test.
If the learning style hypothesis is correct,
the results should show better performance.
When the presentation matches the learning style than when they're mismatched.
I tried a very unscientific version of this experiment on the street.
For some people I matched their learning style. So I showed visual learners,
pictures of items, but for other visual learners,
I read out the items instead, bell, penguin,
sun. Okay. I'm maxed up. How many can you remember?
I don't know. Hair, uh, knife, duck, heart,
uh, butterfly, apple bicycle guitar.
There's a spider.
Did I say I already trumpet.
Pair, butterfly knife, knife, boat, heart knife.
Heart. I couldn't tell you the rest. That's all I got.
Most people could remember only about five or six things. Yeah. Six, six.
Is not bad. All right.
6, 6, 6 outta 10, which is not bad. Oh, right. That's a customs score handle.
Everyone forgets the handle,
but a few could remember substantially more say eight or nine items.
Bug. I don't know if I said bug guitar, bug I bell spoon,
sun chair. I'm forgetting the last two. That's pretty.
Good. Eight is really good. Oh, cool. 9, 9, 9.
Very impressive.
But the reason didn't seem to be because the presentation matched their
preferred learning style, but because they employed a memory strategy.
So.
Like, as you were showing, I was like making an order in my head. So I was,
as I saw more,
I would just add it to the list and I was repeating the list as I was looking at
them. So I could just say it out. Why did you.
Try a strategy while you were looking at those pictures?
Yeah. So I guess, uh,
I tried like creating a story cuz it's easier to remember a story than just
individual objects. So I try to like tie it all into one story.
This is obviously anecdotal evidence, but rigorous studies,
like the one I outlined have been conducted, for example,
one looked at visualizers versus verbalizer instead of visual versus auditory
learners, the study was computer based.
So first students learning styles were assessed using questions.
Like would you rather read a paragraph or see a diagram in Adam?
The researchers also provided some challenging explanations with two buttons,
visual help or verbal help. The visual one played a short animation.
Whereas the verbal help gave a written explanation from these measures combined,
the researchers categorized the students as either visualizers or verbalizes.
And then the students were randomly to go through a text based or picture based
lesson on electronics when a student hovered their mouse over keywords in the
lesson, in the text based group, a definition and clarification came up.
But in the picture group, an annotated diagram was shown instead.
And after the lesson, the students did a test to assess their learning.
The students whose for learning style matched their instruction performed
no better on the tests than those whose instruction was mismatched.
The researchers ran the test again with 61 non-college educated adults and found
exactly the same result, but learning styles are a preference.
So how strongly do learners stick to their preference? Well,
in a 2018 study during the first week of semester,
over 400 students at a university in Indiana completed the VA questionnaire
and they were classified according to their learning style.
Then at the end of the semester,
the same students completed a study strategy questionnaire.
So how did they actually study during the term will an overwhelming majority of
students use study strategies which were supposedly incompatible with their
learning style and the minority of students who did,
did not perform significantly differently on the assessments. In the course,
the visual auditory reading,
writing kinesthetic or VA model came about from Neil Fleming,
a school inspector in New Zealand describing the origins of VA.
He says I was puzzle when I observed excellent teachers who did not reach some
learners and poor teachers who did I decided to try to solve this puzzle.
There are of course, many reasons for what I observed,
but one topic that seemed to hold some magic,
some explanatory power was preferred modes of learning modal preferences.
And thus VA was born.
There was no study that revealed students naturally cluster into four distinct
groups,
just some magic that might explain why some teachers can reach students while
others can't. But how can this be?
If we accept that some people are more skilled at interpreting and remembering
certain kinds of stimuli than others like visual or auditory,
then why don't we see differences in learning or recall with different
presentations?
Well it's because what we actually want people to recall is not the precise
nature of the images or the pitch or quality of the sound.
It's the meaning behind the presentations.
There are some tasks that obviously require the use of a particular modality.
Learning about music. For example, should have an auditory component. Similarly,
learning about geography will involve looking at maps and some people will have
greater aptitude to learn one task over another. Someone with perfect pitch,
for example, will be better able to recall certain tones in music.
Someone with T visual spatial reasoning will be better at learning the locations
of countries on a map.
But the claim of learning style theories is that these preferences will be
consistent across learning domains.
The person with perfect pitch should learn everything better auditorially but
that is clearly not the case. Most people will learn geography better with a map
review articles of learning styles consistently conclude there is no credible
evidence that learning styles exist in a 2009 review.
The researchers note the contrast between the enormous popularity of the
learning styles approach within education and the lack of credible evidence for
its utility is in our opinion, breaking and disturbing.
If classification of students learning styles has practical utility,
it remains to be demonstrated. What.
We're expecting is if your style was honored,
you're gonna perform better than if you had some experience that conflicted with
your style.
And this is where we don't see any support for the learning styles theory.
One of the reasons many people find learning styles.
So convincing is because they already believe it to be true. For example,
they may already think that they're a visual learner.
And then when a teacher shows them a diagram of say a bike pump and suddenly the
concept clicks well,
they interpret this as evidence for their visual learning style. You.
Already believe that learning styles is right when you have an experience.
The first thing you think is is that in some way,
consistent with learning styles. And if it is, you don't.
Think further when in reality,
that diagram might just be a great diagram that would've helped anyone learn.
When we already believe the world to be a certain way,
then we interpret new experiences to fit with those beliefs,
whether they actually do or no. Not.
So if learning styles don't improve learning, then what does well,
there's a large body of literature that supports the claim that everyone learns
better with multimodal approaches,
where words and pictures are presented together rather than either words or
pictures alone.
Now there's gonna be words as well as the picture we're gonna see if this is any
better. This is known as the multimedia effect. And it explains in part,
at least why videos can be such powerful tools for learning when the narration
compliments the visuals duck
part in my PhD research,
I found explicit discussion of misconceptions was essential in multimedia
teaching for introductory physics. How many is that? Six. Six. Okay.
That's good. That is a whole 50% better. Do you think that was easier?
That yeah. Yeah. With hundred percent. Yeah. Hundred percent for sure.
Ultimately the most important thing for learning is not the way the information
is presented, but what is happening inside the learner's head,
people learn best when they're actively thinking about the material solving
problems or imagining what happens if different variables change.
I talked about how and why we learn best in my video, the science of thinking.
So check that out. Now,
the truth is there are many evidence based teaching methods that improve
learning, learning styles is just not one of them.
And it is likely given the prevalence of the learning styles misconception that
it actually makes learning worse. I mean, learning styles,
give teachers unnecessary things to worry about,
and they may make some students reluctant to engage with certain types of
instruction and all,
all the time and money spent on learning styles and related training could be
better spent on interventions that actually improve learning.
You are not a visual learner nor an auditory learner,
nor a kinesthetic learner or more accurately.
You are all these kinds of learner in one.
The best learning experiences are those that involve multiple different ways of
understanding the same thing. And best of all,
this strategy works not just for one subset of people,
but for everyone,
this part of the video was sponsored by Google search.
Now there are lots of topics out there that are controversial,
like learning styles. For example,
most people believe learning styles are a thing.
Whereas educational researchers find no robust evidence for them.
And if you search for learning styles,
you'll get lots of sites with resources and quizzes.
But if you search for learning styles, debunked, well,
then you'll find articles about how there is very little evidence for the
learning styles hypothesis.
I think one of the most common traps people fall into is only searching for
information that confirms what they already believe.
A common mistake is putting the answer you're looking for right in the search
query. A better idea is to try another search,
adding debunked or false at the end and see what comes up and Google makes it
easy to get more detail about the source of the,
just click the three dots next to any search result.
And then you can judge for yourself whether the information is trustworthy.
And if you want to visit the site,
a Google search is meant to surface the most relevant information for your
query, but it's up to you to formulate that query,
try a few different searches and assess whether the information is reliable.
And the whole point of AASS him is to get to the truth.
So I'm excited to encourage everyone to think more critically about how we get
information. I wanna thank Google for sponsoring this part of the video,
and I wanna thank you for watching.